now you said you like math but thank you
you're one smart cookie McKenna Grace
and we're totally impressed
you've been acting since you were six
years old and you're truly remarkable
you sprinkle everything you do with
dedication and intelligence so we
weren't too surprised to find out that
you're smarter than the average person
after all you do have a very impressive
acting portfolio for someone your age do
you know how to differentiate under the
integral sign we couldn't believe how
many kid actors played silly roles to
hide just how smart they were in real
life keep watching to find out which
IndyMac actor is smarter than the
average adult you have to see it to
believe it
McKenna grace there's no use trying to
debate it McKenna grace is one of the
most talented child actors in Hollywood
she kicked off her acting career when
she was only six years old and has been
landing roles
ever since back in 2017 McKenna was cast
as Mary and gifted a movie in which she
portrayed a seven-year-old math whiz how
many seven year olds are doing advanced
calculus funny enough math is McKenna's
favorite subject and she excels at it
McKenna had to memorize some extremely
difficult lines to portray her genius
character my mom and I we turned it into
a song and she did a fantastic job
McKenna is home-schooled and truly
gifted in creative writing and
mathematics Nolan Gould Nolan Gould got
his big break when he was cast as Luke
Dunphy on the hit TV series Modern
Family despite being considered as a boy
genius
Nolan portrays a slightly dense
character with ease put the weasel of my
face believe it or not but Nolan
graduated high school when he was 13
years old he's a member of Mensa which
is a group for individuals with
incredibly high IQs Nolan has an IQ of a
hundred and fifty whereas the average
global IQ can be anywhere from 85 to 115
Chloe Lucas Jack Chloe Lucas Jack is an
eighteen-year-old celebrity who rose to
fame on the reality TV series Dance Moms
Chloe is an extremely gifted dancer but
dancing isn't the only thing she's good
at when it comes to school Chloe is
somewhat of a whiz this star recently
announced that she was accepted into
Pepperdine University in Malibu
California and well Pepperdine isn't an
easy school to get into only students
who have a 3.5 9 GPA or higher are
admitted into the private university so
yeah your girl Chloe is super smart
Atticus Shaffer Atticus Shaffer was born
with osteogenesis imperfecta type 4 but
according to the actor that's just a
small portion of who he is
Atticus started acting when he was 8
years old and quickly became a
well-loved celebrity he voiced PD Fryman
and sour cream on the hit cartoon Steven
universe so much for me and the music
biz in portrayed brick heck on the
middle Atticus is super smart and
considered as a creative genius he knows
everything there is to know about
military history and attributes his many
successes to being homeschooled Lisa
Simpson if there's one kid actor who's
smarter than everyone its Lisa Simpson
sure she's a cartoon but she's still one
of the smartest kids in the world lisa
is a genius who wants to change the
world and make it a better place
[Music]
she's slated to become the president of
the United States in the future but
that's no surprise it's been revealed
that Lisa has an IQ of a hundred and
fifty nine which is downright remarkable
she's a member of Mensa Springfield Rico
Rodriguez Rico Rodriguez rose to fame
when he was cast as Manny Delgado on the
award-winning TV show Modern Family
Rico's character is super intelligent
Manny did we wake you up I'm sorry no I
was doing my science extra credit but
playing him isn't too much of a
challenge considering that Rico is
incredibly smart himself Rico is a
published author who released his first
book when he was just 13 years old
real life lessons so far is known for
being inspiring well-written and
downright hilarious marseilles Martin
fifteen-year-old marseilles Martin got
her big break when she was cast as Diane
John
on the hit series blackish look Aaron
I'm a 10 but Marseille is so much more
than just an actor she's a girl genius
literally Marseille is the youngest
person to executive produce a studio
film and she's also the youngest to sign
a first-look production deal at
Universal this girl is making history
it's such a blessing to me and my family
we're just beyond grateful he and
believe it or not but she started her
very own company at just 14 years old
it's called genius productions for
obvious reasons Rowan Blanchard Rowan
Blanchard isn't your average 17 year old
not only is she mature beyond her years
but she knows how critical it is to be a
role model for her fans
Rowan took up acting when she was five
years old she got her big break when she
was cast as Riley Matthews in Girl Meets
World I never got it before she's an
activist who doesn't shy away from world
wise issues to say that Rowan is
intelligent would be an understatement
she has spoken at the UN Women and us
committees national conference in a
campaign to support feminism Mayim
Bialik you probably know her as Amy
Farrah Fowler from the Big Bang Theory
the me and Bialik is so much more than
an actor yes this is dr. Fowler she
started acting professionally when she
was just a tween but she didn't let her
stardom get in the way of her studies
she was accepted to both Harvard and
Yale however she decided to pursue an
education at UCLA she's a musician who
has mastered the piano trumpet and the
bass guitar and she's also a seasoned
dancer the most impressive of all is the
fact that she has a PhD in neuroscience
Joshua Rush Joshua Rush is a total
smartypants and he's making big changes
all around the world he can speak
English Spanish and Hebrew Joshua is
best known for playing Cyrus Goodman on
Andy Mac I feel weird
different he's highly intelligent and
dreams of becoming a congressman when
he's older he even self-produced a
current affairs program so who is your
favorite kid actor sound off in the
comments thanks for watching the things
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe we'll see you
later
[Music]